sono otto volte che torni da tua moglie
e tua moglie non schiatta questa volta
lo meriterebbe una realtà non
meriterebbero myrick restituì prova
niente comunque ogni volta veramente che
riprende a giocare associato succede
qualcosa
emma moglie e mia
mario che sarà sicuramente in soffitta
find the ma sicuramente non è qui la
presa
certo ci saresti dovuto stare in casa ma
tante di quelle volte che zio forse
inutile che ti incazzi perché
effettivamente sono più le volte che
hanno fatto irruzione in casa mentre non
c'è ricche altro quindi pesaro tesoro si
qua dentro
di qua dentro
no però c'è un ascia io un'ascia per non
saper né leggere le scrive me la porto
aspetta che forse questo si apre questa
non sia prima la porta alla porta o
un'ascia e non ho paura di usarla ko
attenzione maria ci si rivede non so se
prendere mario se prendere lasciano
teniamo lascia guardali adesso è capito
come fanno ad entrare uscire era chiaro
comunque che mano il registratore parte
dottor cornelius funkart open
c'è anche un charter 12 charter udc
durato un minuto va bene ho capito
doveva finire adesso si ricongiungono
adesso nel passato torno in casa e vado
lì sotto scommettete così sia nel
passato che ne è presente sono nello
stesso punto sicuro sicuro sicuro guarda
è ora adesso non sono di nuovo in casa
con lo so io non c'è la predizione
guardalà
il tipo di stati battista propria tirano
dunque ragazzi finisce cosa io lo dico
io finisce che entrambi sia nel passato
che nel futuro cioè che nel presente
finiamo entrambi nella casa entrambi nel
basement io lo so ma basta
ma come fa a essere così veloce
camminando così o stai camminando
no non vale 6 scomparso non vale sta
camminando l'ho visto dai vogliamo che
segue la locanda no come la locanda non
può essere locanda no non me lo fa
finire nella locanda dallo sbagliato
volevo finire in casa mia la locanda
cosa c'entra ma cribbio
non è perciò la finissero in casa mia a
meno che non ci sia un collegamento
negli inferi del demonio ma spunto nel
basement lo so io quanto ci fate che
spunta nel basement io lo so ragazzi lo
so boukris
sono proprio nella tana del demonio
haiti quello nei bot
come si esce di qua ivy no no no no no
no no no io lo sapevo io lo sapevo
come si esce come si va nella nicolas
room così verificare ecco vedi che sono
in casa vedi che sono in casa vedi che è
tutto qui perché tutto qua proprio come
diavolo ci siamo finiti qui ci siamo
dove nascondeva il bambino ma che non
vedo niente
non vedo vabbè seguo anche qualcosa di
far vedere che la dinamite fa esplodere
la miniera
in questo modo sceglie sono entrati in
una porta ma cosa sta succedendo
ma cosa sta succedendo
ecco sta facendo vedere tutto quello che
è successo praticamente questo è quello
che è stato accoltellato prima però in
realtà non è morto perché si sa come sia
possibile la corale mascetti incastrato
cari
però in tutto questo mia moglie dov'è
finita a quest'ora mi avrebbe preso 26
volte è lento come la morte
ok tutto a posto tutto bene un po d'atto
e passa ecco celo celo tranquilli celo
celo celo cori aiuto la madonna che mi
aiuto di disposto a questa questo anche
solo l'idea di due porti pensa mai a
locanda sembrava kaputt
tanto ormai la sua memoria c'è solo
anche i posti dove devo andare
problemi che sono tutti a fuoco qui non
riesco vado riuscire da destra però
riuscita è chiusa qui dove far uscire un
po ecco adesso ad essa dovrebbe esserci
riuscito se non mi cadono gli animali in
faccia
fa niente se lo scaffale mi è cascato in
bocca fa niente è successo di peggio
nella vita ok da in fondo si sta adesso
non so a sinistra in basso giu io dio
destra in fondo a 6 giu store e sul
fondo poi a sinistra viola sono usciti
ma riesco a uscire rendilo tirarglielo
in bocca tirarglielo io glielo
affrontano però sfonda la porta sponda
sono d'acqua siviglia gola che avrebbe
già preso otto volte praticamente tanto
quindi ori madonna e ovunque
chiuditi di sotto vai meraviglioso tante
cose che non ho capito bene però fa
niente capitolo 13 ma si tanto se non
sto capendo nel basement siamo né
paceman la faccia della bestia
ora mi guardo allo specchio perché la
bestia
ci siamo questa è quello che c'è sotto
il mio business la donna che piccoli
bruttissimi regalo programma fargli uno
spavento io jump schiera il contrario
non funziona si siete e tutto il gioco
che così ed è la tua immaginazione 0
complimenti bravo manovale che è
arrivato a questa conclusione
la chicca e vabbè dislocamento inter
stella eccomi finalmente mi si vede che
brutto che sono ok sono entrate nello
specchio
quindi sono veramente entrato nello
specchio vabbè
non sono io nel futuro la maschera
sicuro in qualche modo è legata a sta
cosa in qualche modo legata cioè sono
una cosa che rimane col mistero gli ha
chiesto semplicemente il perche e lui
adesso ci darà una bellissima disco sc
la domanda è perché l'hai fatto
tutto qui tutto qui
a posso decidere io accettato a vera
natura oppure rifiuta la personalità
della personalità malvagia no no io
accetto la mia natura anche figo quindi
a infilare variante ho svegliato la
bestia e questo è l'inizio del gioco ma
questa non è mai quella tipa quindi io
sono il proprio proprio proprio
pronipote di nicolas che ha fatto tutto
sto casino nel passato ma come potete
farmi fare ste scelte quindi ho
accettato la mia vera natura però l'api
alla fine io non posso sparare a lei e
sparma beirut
gran finale proprio bello fido così 9
dai no no no dài dài non mi prendete per
il culo ma veramente
oddio allora di fare due cose vi dicono
al volo la prima penso sia stato
pomeriggio vivo la trama più fitta della
storia però purtroppo tra il fatto che
ci sono stati tanti tagli tra fatelo
perso anche i salvataggi prima e dal
fatto che è impossibile per me tradurre
ogni cosa quindi godersi la trama
dall'inizio alla fine impossibile su
youtube c'è in questo caso in questa
serie
mi dispiace che sia difficile da portare
su youtube a livello di trama però
madonna fatto veramente
bene nord coi contro maroni fighissimo
quindi se proprio vi sia piaciuto un
bacino scegliamo il prossimo video
ragazzi vi ringrazio chi esce dal campo
nella prima nelle sempre aggiornati sui
nuovi video e noi come sempre ci
rivediamo al prossimo video bella
ragazza
[Musica]